♪ ♪
>> NOT ONE MORE AMERICAN LIFE
SHOULD BE LOST BECAUSE OUR
LAWMAKERS FAILED TO SECURE OUR
BORDERS.
THAT IS WHY WE ARE CALLING ON
CONGRESS TO FIX OUR TERRIBLE
IMMIGRATION LAWS.
STOP CATCH AND RELEASE, AND
DEADLY SANCTUARY CITIES, STOP
THE VISA LOTTERY PROGRAM.
>> Laura: AND A LOT MORE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP PREVIEWING WHAT
WE CAN EXPECT TO HEAR THE
OVERALL TOMORROW.
AS WE WITNESSED LAST WEEK IN
SOUTH TEXAS, THIS IS BEYOND
CRISIS POINT NOW.
WE HAVE UPDATES WE WILL BRING
YOU TOMORROW ON NEW MEXICO.
A STORY THAT HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
LOST ON MOST IN THE MEDIA AND WE
ARE TOLD TWO MAIN POINTS ON THE
IMMIGRATION PLAN, SECURITY
BORDER AND INSTITUTING THIS
MERIT-BASED SYSTEM.
THE GOAL IS TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF ILLEGALS DUE TO FAMILY TIES.
RIGHT NOW 66% OF 1 MILLION GREEN
CARDS ARE DOLED OUT BECAUSE OF
FAMILY RELATIONSHIPS AND THEY
WANT TO INVERT THAT TO A
MERIT-BASED.
JOINING US NOW, HOUSE MINORITY
WHIP, IS THERE A COALITION THAT
WOULD SUPPORT FLIPPING THEME
NARRATIVE FROM ENTIRE FAMILY
TREES COMING IN HERE TO PEOPLE
WE NEED BECAUSE THEIR JOBS?
I'M NOT FOR INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS.
I THINK 1.1 MILLION IS ENOUGH.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO KEEP IT AT
THE SAME NUMBER AND NOT REDUCE
IT.
>> THERE IS NO TALK OF
INCREASING, THERE IS TALK ON
GETTING BACK TO RULE OF LAW AND
SECURING THE BORDER AND GOING TO
A MERIT-BASED SYSTEM.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SOME OF THE
DOMESTIC LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
WE EDUCATE SOMEONE TO BE A
COMPUTER SCIENTIST, THEY WANT TO
STAY IN AMERICA AND WE FORCE
THEM TO LEAVE THE COUNTRY TO
COMPETE AGAINST US.
WE HAVE THE VISA LOTTERY WHERE
WE LITERALLY PLUG NAMES OUT OF A
HAT.
WHY DON'T WE FLIP THAT
NARRATIVE.
GIVE CAPS ON DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES.
IF YOU ARE COMING FROM INDIA HE
WENT WERE 20 YEARS BUT IF YOU'RE
COMING FROM HONDURAS YOU MIGHT
WAIT SIX YEARS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE FAMILY TREE
ISSUE.
LET'S GET TO A MERIT-BASED
SYSTEM WHERE WE HAVE RULE OF LAW
WE GET BACK TO THOSE BASIC
FOUNDATIONAL PRINCIPLES WHERE
YOU COME TO AMERICA.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SEEING VIDEO
OF WHAT I SAW LAST WEEK AT THE
BORDER WHICH IS BASICALLY
PEOPLE --
I LOVE THE GUY FILMING THIS.
PEOPLE JUST WAITING FOR THE
PATROL AND THEY ARE PULLING THEM
UP AND PROCESSING THEM AND
24 HOURS AND RELEASING THEM.
THAT GOES TO THE ASYLUM LAW,
LINDSEY GRAHAM WANTS TO ADDRESS.
ARE THE DEMOCRATS GOING TO AGREE
TO ANY OF THIS?
WILL THEY OWN THE ISSUES?
>> DEMOCRATS AND MIDDLE AMERICA
ARE ACTUALLY FULL      FOR THIS.
IT SHOWS THE DIVIDE.
YOU HAVE TO END CATCH AND
RELEASE, THESE MAGNETS THAT ARE
FORCING PEOPLE TO COME HERE AND
THE BREAKDOWNS, THAT WILL BE
SOME OF THE THINGS.
>> Laura: WE HAD 100,000
PEOPLE JUST COMING IN LAST MONT
MONTH.
ONE OF THE FAVORITE GLOBAL
ANALYST SAID THIS.
>> YOU CANNOT DEVELOP POLICY OF
PEOPLE AND COMPASSION, IT
RESULTS NOT JUST AND HURT
INDIVIDUALS BUT ALSO HURT
FAMILIES.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING IS IF YOU HAVE TO BE
AMAZINGLY BRILLIANT, YOU HAVE TO
BE WIDER.
THIS IS REMINISCENT TO BE OF
WHAT HAPPENED BEFORE THE CIVIL
RIGHTS BEGAN.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT.
>> DO THEY HAVE ANY IDEA OF WHAT
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT?
WHAT TO TELL SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN WAITING IN LINE LEGALLY FOR
TEN YEARS TO COME TO AMERICA.
YOU HAVE LAWS THAT ALLOW PEOPLE
TO GO IN FRONT?
YOU CAN COME HERE ILLEGALLY IN
PLACE OF THE PERSON THAT HAS
BEEN WAITING IN LINE TEN YEARS.
>> Laura: TWO-POINT SYSTEM, I
WANT TO SEE HOW THIS PLAYS OUT.
THE OFFER OF EMPLOYMENT ABOVE A
CERTAIN WAGE THRESHOLD,
VOCATIONAL CERTIFICATION.
I THINK IN THE END THIS ISSUE IS
PROPERLY MESSAGED WILL BE
ANOTHER HUGE WINNER FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
ALTHOUGH HIS NUMBERS ARE NOT
GOOD ON IMMIGRATION.
HAVE YOU SEEN THIS?
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE SEEING THESE VIDEOS
ENTER FRUSTRATED LIKE WHY
DOESN'T HE FIX THIS.
HIS NUMBERS FOR SYNDICATION ARE
NOT WHERE HE WANTS THEM TO BE.
>> MY BEEN TO A LOT OF SWING
STATES, THERE ARE THE LINES TO
SEE THIS PRESIDENT ARE
UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Laura: TELL ME ABOUT IT.
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU RAISED.
>> A MILLION DOLLARS AND IT WAS
SOLD OUT.
PEOPLE WERE TURNED AWAY.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS STOOD UP FOR
THE THINGS HE HAS PROMISED AND
HE HAS A GOOD IMMIGRATION PLAN.
>> Laura: 4 MILLION, ONE NIGHT
AND NEW ORLEANS.